women in Saudi Arabia are pressing for
their freedom and they're beginning to
get it Holly Williams has been in the
kingdom for the past week she is seeing
the change firsthand as women trained in
gyms get set to drive and become more
integrated but there are still limits
Holly Williams in Jeddah Saudi Arabia to
show us how society though is changing
Holly good morning good morning Saudi
women face some very big challenges
including the male guardianship system
which means they need a male relatives
permission to travel overseas or get
married but things here are beginning to
shift if you think that Saudi Arabian
women are all oppressed shrouded and
weak you probably need to see this there
are not victims we are not victims we
are strong Halla Elohim Ronnie runs the
fight like a girl boxing gym in Jeddah
she has a passion for combat sports are
you pushing for total equality I mean as
much yes that would be great but is
there total equality for women and men
around the world not yet so hopefully
eventually yes and hopefully in my
lifetime there are big changes in Saudi
Arabia women are joining the workforce
in record numbers and next year they'll
finally be allowed to drive after more
than two decades of protests by Saudi
standards the country's new Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman is a reformer and
it's not just women who feel more
liberated take a look at Saudi Arabia's
stand-up comedy scene in this ultra
conservative Islamic Kingdom they still
find plenty to laugh at though this is
no democracy and there are red lines the
sex and religions and this Trump job I
don't know it's drum job but politics
yes exactly Suleiman al sham retold us
his comic influences are American Dave
Chappelle Kevin Hart and Chris Rock I
take from Chris Rock nobody know don't
tell me anymore
you stole I do it I don't nobody know
because I
it's rock I'm sorry but so do nobody
know if you come in sorry I'm not safe
and I apologize many Saudis are fearful
of criticizing their government but at
this conservative mosque some of the
faithful told us they're disturbed by
this speed of change and especially
mixing between the sexes in a place
where gender segregation has been the
norm there's always the possibility of a
backlash from religious conservatives
but most Saudis we've spoken to both
women and men are hoping that doesn't
happen
Gayle all right Holly Williams reporting
from Saudi Arabia
something tells me Chris Rock wouldn't
mind that he takes a joke what is that
saying imitation is the most sincere
form of flattery flattery I could take
it on a road yeah oh there have Chris
Rock there and then bring him over to
the United States he's got a great sense
of humor Chris would like that tells me
thank you again Holly